trevor bauer john he's as good as it
gets in major league baseball he has
made himself into one heck of a pitcher
ashley ranks this season era 1.74 second
and the pitch from bauer it's a fastball
and it's grounded up the middle of bay's
hit between the second baseman mike
mustakas and the second base bag
you know and that's a nice little swing
just protecting on a fastball down and
away not a bad pitch but gonzales able
to get on top of it two buckos aboard
and moran is the cleanup man
and into the glove of barnhart off the
foul tip and it's the first strikeout
for bauer well when bauer needs that
breaking ball he's able to deal it on to
moran bauer again back to the plate with
the 2-2 pitch to bell swing and a miss
struck him out with a breaking ball in
the dirt josh bell down on strikes
trevor bauer with back to back punch
outs to close out the first cody ponce
is back out there for the pirates to
make another start the 29th man once
again two balls in a strike on vato 12
walks shy of the reds franchise record
this ball hit in the air to center
fairly deep but
the center fielder brian reynolds in
front of the track about five steps
makes the catch kevin newman now
starting at second base and the pitch to
newman there's a breaking ball that's
bounced to third oh off the glove of
suarez the third baseman into foul
territory and it's first and second
don't let the hop play you that's kind
of what happened with suarez but to
his defense he was trying to set up so
he could have a play at second but it
hit right off his knee going under his
glove now bauer faced with some
adversity here cole tucker the hitter
kicks them off and down goes tucker boy
did he pull the string on that third
strikeout for bauer the 2-2 pit swing
gonna miss he struck him out
bauer works out of the jam in the second
once again back-to-back punch-outs the
red starter that is out number one and
it brings up mike mustakas one ball
two-strike count pitch
strike three call that was a dandy fast
paul to mustaches inside corner yeah the
moose didn't like it thought it was a
little bit in off the plate
but uh boy that's
a good spot you're heading to count the
2-2 pitch breaking ball and it's bounce
left side shortstop gonzalez gobbles it
up and throws on to get him one two
three for cody ponce we've played two
bucks nothing reds nothing probably
seemed like forever since nick sinzell
stepped into a major league batters box
but here he is back off the i o after
missing 27 games balls chopped toward
third hayes edge of the grass throws a
strike to first to retire senzel
here's the wind in the pitch from ponce
swing and a miss fastball rides in and
ties him up strikes him out through
three reds nothing
colin moran who struck out in the first
will lead off against trevor bauer
strike three called on moran five of
them for bauer i'm not sure what colin
moran's looking for right here but he
gets a fastball 3-2 and can't get the
bat off his shoulder here's the one-two
swing and a miss strike three reynolds
down on strikes bowers punched out six
through four shoko akiyama whom he
walked in the first but akiyama was
caught stealing pots with another 2-2
pitch and a swing and a miss out in
front and that's strikeout number three
for cody joybottom fly to centerfield
his first time up two outs nobody on
nothing nothing bottle with the drive
into left field joey bottle will touch
them all
home cooking number eight bravado in a
one-nothing reds lead another record
into the reds books those strikeouts
through nine appearances trevor bauer
with 77 of them flipping johnny cueto
down goes newman seven punch outs for
trevor bauer
[Applause]
see you see you later back to back punch
outs three in a row for bauer make that
four of the last five batters he struck
out there you go
and a fastball strength recall right
over the outside corner murphy doesn't
like it back to the dugout as a three-up
three-down inning for bauer he's retired
11 in a row nick castiano's to the plate
with the bases juiced and two down 373
batter career with the bases loaded five
grannies
and it's a drive towards center field
back is reynolds to the wall he makes
the catch two steps shy of the wall it's
the reds one pirate number has nine
strikeouts overall has given up one hit
down goes gonzalez five strikeouts in a
row he has it going on fourth
double-digit strikeout game of the
season a one-two pitch strike three
called 11 punch-outs for trevor bauer
trevor bauer returns to the mound to try
to finish this one off for the reds in
the top of the seventh inning the 1-1
pitch on its way and it's a fly ball hit
deep to right field aquino to the wall
and it is
gone colin moran don't you know
has tied the game
at 1-1 now the go-ahead run in scoring
position bauer's day is going to be done
there's beyond the move
strike three call and they will give the
rookie tyler stevenson a chance
in the air left field hit pretty well
tyler stevenson goodbye
tyler stevenson a walk-off
home run